started so um this is the fourth in a
monthly series that we're doing on
worlds of of speculative
fiction um and this time we're doing CS
Lewis we we've already done Jr tolken
great you know fantasy writer uh AE van
Voit a great science fiction writer and
we've got others yet to come in months
ahead but I wanted to get Lewis in right
away in part because um I want to get to
reread Lewis early on but but also
because he ends up being so influential
so we're trying to build towards the
people who were influenced from the
people who are
influencing um what I wanted to focus on
for this is Lewis's somewhat lesser
known known uh series it's called the
the space Trilogy although he didn't
like that name um so he he preferred to
call it the ransom Trilogy after the the
main character in a lot of these so
that's out of the Silent Planet uh
paralandra and That Hideous Strength um
you know he's he's a lot better known
for the Narnia books and for his
apologetic writing but these are
actually for me and for some of the
people who like his work
um among the the best of his his
writings and um since I I don't I I've
introduced myself to I know you but I've
introduced myself before I'm Greg Sadler
I'm a local author and speaker and and
philosopher um and I'm also a big
Science Fiction and Fantasy fan so when
I pitched this series the idea was that
I could indulge my my guilty pleasures
that's why they couldn't find you they
had you listed as a philosophy group oh
when I asked at the front desk they said
well there's a philosophy group meeting
yeah well we do explore philosophical
themes in in these but it's um you know
it's not like a philosophy class or
anything like that so um so what I'm
going to do is uh we usually go through
sort of a a bio you know
biographical um discussion first about
you know where this guy fit in uh any
really interesting Keynotes uh or
eccentricities
and um Lewis had a few uh admittedly uh
and then we'll talk about you know where
the trilogy fits into that um then I
want to give an overview of the general
plot and we can get into some discussion
there and then I've got some some
philosophical themes picked out that I
thought were particularly interesting
but we can always talk about other ones
that if you you know you guys have read
the books I'm guess I've not okay well
not in a long time okay some things
might come to mind or you know if if you
have ideas we can stop at any time I'm
I'm great with digressions and questions
and answers and then coming back on to
to to the path so I've got four
philosophical themes picked out um myth
and metaphysics is the first one
rational animals is the second um what
Lewis called
scientism and uh lesser goods and evil
is the third and then um his distinction
which he doesn't flesh out very much but
it was quite interesting sex and gender
that comes up in these uh is is another
one before that I'd like to do two
things one is to talk about why I picked
these in in
particular um so Lewis has been a you
know a favorite of mine since I was in
Elementary School uh I remember actually
having The Lion the Witch and the
Wardrobe read to us during art class
which was quite cool schol um you know
our teacher would have us I know doing
whatever we were doing paper mâché or
things like that come on in hi Hi and
then um we would um she would read it
the the book to us and we didn't get to
the the end of it of course by the end
of the the year um not quite sure why
because it's not that long but uh that
got me interested and I started reading
his other things I read them out of
order uh the next one I read was the
horse and his boy um
and uh then I started you know just
fting the rest and then uh I remember in
high school being bored by by Lewis by
teachers assigning his apologetic works
and and then um rediscovering Lewis you
know with the screw tape letters and
saying well this is actually great stuff
and then I just sort of Let It lay for a
long time I didn't read these until I
was in my late 30s and they they've been
recommended over and over and over again
and I always thought thought yeah you
know if it's like the Narnia stuff
that's for kids I don't know that I want
to read that um and I I I would have
enjoyed reading them much earlier but
when I did finally get to read them they
were really a revelation to me um Lewis
was a classical scholar uh he he was a a
great um literary interpreter and he was
also uh interested in philosophy and he
folds that into these books so for
somebody like me um that was very
attractive
um I would like to tell you a little bit
about some of the um you might say sort
of the skeleton uh of of these stories
or how they fit into a
genre in an earlier uh session I I
brought up tokens on fairy tales uh
which is a great essay that he wrote
about about fantasy literature and one
of the things that he says in that is
even fairy tales as a whole have three
three faces so they're not always the
same he says there's the mystical
towards the
supernatural the magical towards nature
and the mirror of scorn and pity towards
man the essential face of what he called
fairy which was the realm of fantasy is
the middle one the magical but the
degree in which the others appear if at
all is variable and may be decided by
the individual Storyteller so the reason
I brought that up is this this Trilogy
is supposed to be science fiction right
so we'd expect it not to have fantasy
elements um and it does have some
fantasy elements but it also has this
entire
theological backdrop to it that's that's
woven in a very non preachy non
catechetical way um so it has that face
of the mystical towards the supernatural
but it's not the supernatural in the
sense of horror stories uh nor is it the
supernatural like reading a catechism or
or a work of traditional theology it's
something different going on here the
other author who I wanted to bring up is
George Orwell George Orwell said that
this book was not very good um and and
actually um critics when they talk about
That Hideous Strength they they tend to
say that these two first books are
better than the the last one some people
actually don't like paralandra they say
that one's just you know Christian uh
Doctrine you know narrowly disguised um
I I don't think they're actually right
about that but Orwell has this to say it
says Mr Lewis probably owes something to
Chesterton as a writer and certainly
shares his horror of modern machine
civilization and his Reliance on the
Eternal varities of the Christian church
as against scientific materialism or
nihilism one could recommend this book
unreservedly if Mr Lewis had succeeded
in keeping it all on a single level
unfortunately the supernatural keeps
breaking in and it does so in rather
confusing undisciplined ways and then he
goes on he says Lewis is entitled to his
beliefs but they weaken his story not
only because they offend the average
reader sense of probability but because
in effect they decide the issue in
advance when one is told that God and
the devil are in Conflict one always
knows which side is going to win the
whole drama of the struggle against evil
lies in the fact that one does not have
Supernatural Aid and think about Orwell
he's somebody who really was thinking
quite a lot about evil and the struggle
against evil so he's charging Lewis
basically with writing allegory for for
Christian doctrine and what I'd like to
suggest is that um although you know in
the end yes the the good side is going
to win you don't actually know that when
you're reading through the books so I
think Orwell may have been kind of a
careless reader and not attentive to how
much the characters themselves are
thrown into suspense Lewis is able to uh
make it seem like evil might Triumph o
over good in in many cases um the other
thing too I have to do before we go into
the sort of biography talk a little bit
about the origin of the these stories so
um tolken was a friend of Lewis and they
were members of this group The
inklings tolken didn't follow through on
his his obligation with respect to this
Lewis did in writing this book um both
of them were talking about science
fiction which was not a highly regarded
genre at the time but was quite popular
and they're saying it's too bad that the
science fiction stuff tends to be also
you know technologically focused and you
know science is going to solve
everything um this is before you know
the the new wave of of science fiction
or may that that kind of interesting
developments and so Lewis and tolken
said well let's write some stories you
know and and and tolken said all right
you write uh a story of about space
travel and I'll write a story about time
travel and tolken started writing it
never actually finished it it it got you
know what he did get um written got
published later on after his death I
forget the name of the story exactly but
um Lewis wrote A Space story out of the
Silent Planet the Silent Planet is Earth
and it's a trip to Mars and then back
again and then this one is a followup
this is a trip to Venus and and Back
Again and then this one's just on Earth
but the the planets come down to earth
so it's kind of a trip in that sense as
well um so let's let's talk now about
about Lewis's biography you can see with
the um timeline that I gave you he's
born
1898 um his mother dies uh when he's
pretty young and um he he grows up in
Ireland uh for the most part and then
comes to England to to study and then to
fight on on the side of the English you
it's uh uh involved in the first world
war pretty pretty early is wounded and
uh you know is placed back in England to
convalesce and uh ends up being
demobilized um he begins living with
this woman Jane Moore who was a friend
of or she was the mother of one of his
friends he will live with her throughout
most of his his life um and take care of
her they they'd actually made a
agreement that you know whoever if in
the war one of them died um they would
take care of each other's family so so
he does that uh and then he becomes a
you know sort of typical Professor he's
he's um studying he becomes a tutor he
uh gets himself a post teaches has has a
pretty nice academic life uh traditional
academic life and he meets uh tolken and
before he joins the inklings he joins
this this group group that tolken has
organized to study Norse literature
called the kitar and then he gets
involved with the inklings and the
inklings are you know what would you
call it like a writing group um but you
know it's it's not just a a bunch of
random people getting together at a
bookstore these are some pretty
high-powered writers getting together to
joke around to you know throw story
ideas out there and to read and critique
each other's St
like Dorothy Parker's Circle and that
kind of thing exactly
really uh I me it must crial of one
another's work challenging one another
yeah you know speaking of critical
tolken didn't like the Narnia stories he
thought that they were uh you know kind
of implausible poorly put together uh he
tried he tried reading him and then he's
like I'm giving up on this um those are
written later on after after this stuff
but now now um Lewis interestingly is an
atheist at the time that he goes to to
uh College um he's one of those atheist
who lost his faith so he's not an
atheist who grows up without any
religious convictions instead he he's
like a deliberate atheist he said this
is nonsense you know and you know uh I
think if if you look at the Ireland of
his time you can understand the you know
his sort of rebelliousness against that
um and then he he f doesn't become a
Christian right away first he becomes a
theist you know this is a philosophical
term that we use to talk in a general
sense about anybody who believes in any
sort of God right but when it's got a
capital T it usually means a person who
believes in you know some kind of God
but it's not quite determined what it is
right and so he starts out with that and
then eventually he becomes a a a
Christian and he uh joins the Anglican
Church Church of England um tolken is a
little a little bit disappointed because
tolken was hoping to bring him into the
Catholic Church um but you know they're
pretty close and now you notice um the
books start piling up he starts
publishing quite a bit of stuff um he
publishes this Pilgrim's regress which
gets terrible reviews uh it's kind of a
blow to his his ego and then he starts
publishing other stuff the allegory of
Love A study in medieval tradition great
book um you know that that's actually a
good book to read for background to this
sort of stuff it's a uh it's a study
right so it's a a traditional academic
work but um he's he's very good at
explaining how um how people use symbols
how they understood those sorts of
things and then you notice the next
stuff after this out of the Silent
Planet um he starts you know doing some
apologetic Works um and then um
paralandra comes out That Hideous
Strength
and then it just sort of goes on from
there
um he ends up marrying later in life
this is been dramatized in um that movie
shadowlands um and uh you know he
doesn't actually get to enjoy marriage
very long unfortunately his wife gets
cancer dies he uh brings up uh her two
boys as as his
own um and then you know it's not much
longer after that he suffers from blood
poisoning recovers from that and then
has a heart attack um and will
eventually succumb to renal failure his
death is not really marked um notice
what day he dies on November 22nd why is
that F important
day yeah so they die on the same day
Kennedy gets all the news because he's a
president and um Mother Teresa what's
that the Mother Teresa did she die in
the 22nd no she didn't she die the same
day as Princess Diana right I think so
yeah
yeah oh really yeah okay well you know
who else died uh on the same day too
with these two those guys uh Huxley
ohley yeah nobody nobody noticed that
either I mean k died right so no exactly
I mean so that's that's sort of the the
timeline and you can see that the
trilogy um comes in pretty early in his
career you know um it's not that long
after um he starts to to you know become
kind of a name now
um Let me let me talk a little bit about
the the plot
so this is going to be very rough
because there's a lot going on here but
I I do want to give you some flavor for
for what's going on um and and it fits
in with the this notion of Worlds and I
created a handout for you that helps you
kind of keep track of where things are
going with this this field of Aral you
know so the field of arall is the name
that Lewis um is going to bring up and
have some of his characters and some of
the forces used to talk about our solar
system and I suppose if you had to say
in one you know phrase what you know one
of the key underpinnings for this entire
thing is that our perspective on things
is is very partial and covers up a much
deeper perspective you could say and
Lewis introduces us to that through
through the characters and um the
interactions with with other uh beings
in it so
um you've got this guy Ransom and I
mentioned that this is often called The
Ransom uh series Ransom is the main
character in the first two books and
then he shows up as an important
character in this Hideous Strength he's
a philologist and a philologist nowadays
we would call them linguists but
philology didn't just mean um studying
living languages it involved usually
dead languages as well you know uh
medieval Latin for example or classical
Greek or Sanskrit and so Ransom is a guy
who who handles languages um he's really
modeled after sort of a mixture of H and
Lewis he's got some of the same
features uh he fought in World War I
like they did got wounded in World War
One like Lewis did so there's there's a
bit of autobiographical stuff there and
as they'll remind uh one of the
characters will remind him later on his
name actually means elf friend so that's
pretty tolken is right there right and
Ransom is out doing this walking tour in
in England and he comes across um a
woman who's who's upset because uh her
son who's not not very bright is off
with these guys at a country house and
um Ransom actually agrees to go and get
her son and it turns out that um when he
gets there these two characters um
Weston and and divine Divine is somebody
that Ransom went to school with and was
kind of a nasty guy in school kind of a
climber type um they're bullying this
kid and trying to get him to to go into
some sort of apparatus and Ransom sends
the kid home and then they say well
let's let's talk about this and then
they drug him and then they take him to
Mars which B they've got a spaceship
right turns out that Weston is This
brilliant scientist and he's been
working on a spaceship now all the
science in in the science fiction this
is pretty
implausible um Lewis doesn't pretend you
know to to explain any of this uh in a
way it's kind of period uh HG Wells is
and stuff uh Wells also had some rather
implausible stuff in his things as well
but they they're taking him to Mars and
one of the first Revelations that Lewis
uh gives us in this is that space isn't
even remotely like what we picture it as
um now this is before of course we've
been out in space he's he's imagining
things but space turns out to be this
glorious place um which which is almost
intoxicating to be in
um it it's not just an empty horrible
void the way the people have been
portraying it and they they travel for a
very long time and then finally arrive
at
Mars and there's been sort of you know
uh conversations going on hinting at
what what might be going on um Ransom is
smart enough to get himself a knife and
and you know hide it um and as soon as
soon as they land he takes off he says I
I'm not hang out with these guys
uh anything is better than than you know
spending it with with these in part
we'll talk about why Weston is such a
terrible guy in a bit and why why Divine
is is a pretty bad guy as well um he
thinks that he's being brought to Mars
or he surmises he's being brought to
Mars to be a
sacrifice to these creatures called the
uh the sorns or seron as their the way
that that they describe themselves and
they're these giant humanoid creat
creatures that are pretty scary looking
at first so Ransom takes off and he runs
and he gets away um and he winds up with
these other creatures that are called
the the Rosa they're they're described
as being kind of otter likee um you know
think about otters they like to play
around they like water and all that but
they're
intelligent they he he's able to learn
their language and the language they
speak is actually the language of it's
called Old solar it's the language of
the whole solar system just not spoken
on on Earth um and he spends a lot of
time with them he enjoys their company
they have poetry they decide they're
going to go on this great hunt to you
know try to catch and kill this one
creature that's sort of like a cross
between a crocodile and a few other
things um at the same time he's he's
also told that he's supposed to go and
um and correspond with or clock with uh
this this uh being that's called an an
elil and and elil you could think of it
is sort of like an angel kind of thing
uh although it's explained in purely
physical terms as as you know being a
creature that is just not composed the
way that we material creatures are it
moves at a different rate um they're
hard to see and they're they're
spiritual creatures they they kind of
run the show of of the planet um and
he's told that he needs to go to talk to
the chief one of the planet the O the um
oara of of the the planet um and he
delays he doesn't do it instead he goes
on the hunt with his his good friend uh
hii and um they manage to kill the the
creature and then hio gets killed by by
uh Divine and Weston who shoot him and
now uh it's you know it's revealed to to
Ransom that he probably should have
followed the instructions in the first
place and he better get on with his
quest um and so he does it uh so he
travels through the the highlands the
the mountains and he starts meeting
these these sorns and he finds out that
they're not these terrifying creatures
at all they're rational creatures
they're good they just you know they're
put together in a different way than
humans or the HOSA um they have their
own peculiar sense of humor even he
describes them and it turns out that
there's several kinds of intelligence
beings on this planet rational beings as
Le will call it so he meets the third
race which is uh very diff difficult to
pronounce it's uh the fil fil all right
and I'm not going to say that anymore
I'll just call it third group yeah nice
job yeah um some of these things I have
a very hard time
pronouncing um so anyway he he um he
goes to the ARA and he finds out that
each planet has one of these great
beings running it and he finds out why
our planet is called the Silent Planet
all the other planets things go more or
less the way they're supposed to our
planet is the Screwed Up place because
our oara decided that he wanted to
control everything and made war on on
the other ones um sort of broke the
cosmic plan and got pushed back back
beyond the the orbit of the the moon and
now it's it's the Silent Planet no no
signal goes out from there although um
god um uh Mal alil comes to the planet
at at one point in time and takes on the
form of one of the intelligent life
there human beings and tries to you know
stir things up back in the the ancient
past
um so
so you could think of this as sort of
like a revelation that what what seemed
to be horror isn't horror things
actually fall into place but the book
ends by bringing Weston and divine in
and the oara trying to make sense out of
them and Weston gives this speech which
is really kind of kind of funny if you
if you've ever if you ever read it um he
he thinks that these people are just
kind of Natives and he talks down to
them and then it tells them that you
know human beings get to expand
throughout the Universe because we
represent the highest form of life and
we'll destroy everything else so you
know essentially the rest of you too bad
for you you know you had your your time
now it's the the reign of the human
beings so the AR says well can't stick
around here and you guys aren't coming
back either so they sends them back to
Earth and um they manag to get there
before this this deadline runs out um
Ransom is being protected by by these
these you know Heavenly or or spiritual
creatures ill and that's the end of the
book um and then with a little twist at
the end it's published as a science
fiction story because nobody would
believe it
otherwise so that's the first book in
the second book um Ransom is now taken
uh on a mission to to ven
which is called
paralandra and he's sent in this this
glass coffin that you know flies through
the air and he's supposed to be like an
agent of of uh God or mal Malil he
arrives and he finds himself on this
vast sea of not salt water but fresh
water and it's a very beautiful world um
it's temperate it's almost like an Eden
and it turns out it actually is an Eden
it's a new world um in which um human
beings are just starting
out and he finds you know a floating
island uh gets on the island um there's
all sorts of great descriptions you know
Lewis is great for for um giving us
images of what this would be like not
only about sights but sounds and and
feelings he finds things to eat and then
he runs into the first woman the eve of
that planet the the queen who's green um
but you know otherwise more or less like
us and um you know they talk for a while
they do things everything is going along
well and then Weston shows up so Weston
is is becoming a recurring character and
now Weston you know tells him that uh he
was actually wrong about um this you
know human being should dominate
everything he's converted to a kind of
spiritualism that's modeled roughly
after hre ber s's Creative Evolution
idea uh which by the way Lewis actually
liked quite a bit he was he was very uh
taken with with bone at one point but
Weston is coming if if if uh Ransom is
coming as an agent of God Weston is
coming as an agent of something else um
he ends up becoming possessed by a
diabolical force and this diabolical
Force wants to screw things up for these
first humans and he starts to work on
the uh the woman um and he also starts
to work on the environment he he
tortures creatures just for the sake of
doing so there's a really horrific uh
scene where um there's these frog likee
creatures that um Weston who who once
he's possessed has these very sharp
nails is is cutting these creatures open
and peeling their their skin off and
just letting them die like that um and
so Ransom comes across one of them and
finds it like that and then kills it
takes him about an hour to kill it and
he realizes like probably made it suffer
more in the process but I needed to end
its suffering and then he walks a couple
more steps and he sees another one and
another one and another one and another
one that's the kind of creature that
that he's dealing with in in Weston and
Weston wants to try to corrupt these
these um first you know human beings
into breaking the rules that they've
been given and so there's a lot of
interesting theological discussion
that's not framed in terms of theology
but framed in terms of um
you know you might call it everyday
actions and and sensuous things about
about goods and bads and how one ought
to behave um he also tries to drive
random
nuts he'll he'll just you know do
childish things like sit there and say
random random random till he replies
after about the thousandth reply and
then he'll say nothing you know what did
you want
nothing you know so there's some really
interesting descriptions there about
what what um the uh battle that's taking
place or the debate that's taking place
between them in Tales and eventually
Weston has this
realization that he's there not just to
try to you know be you know a champion
in
argument he's actually supposed to use
physical force and kill
Weston um which terrifies him because
Weston is possessed and Weston has these
nails that are like Claws and he's
thinking how am I going to be up to this
I'm a middle-aged sedentary scholar who
never really recovered from his wound in
the war you want me to take on a
possessed you know human being and he
goes through this long argument I've got
a handout here on on some of that
discussion that'll be quite interesting
to to talk about um but but he does he
he goes after he he he uh takes on
Weston and he manages to do all right in
fighting him and Weston actually takes
off uh and random pursues it and Ransom
and and they have the pursuit takes
place uh for quite a while they actually
end up you know mounting on these
fishes uh and and you know not sailing
but I guess riding them out uh quite a
ways and there's a last confrontation
between the two of them where where
Weston says a uh you know things that
Express his his point of view and then
they fight and they go under the water
and they wind up in a
cave uh and then Ransom has to climb his
way out in the darkness with what's now
a a dead corpse still possessed pursuing
him in the
darkness uh through the climb and he
finally does kill the corpse crushing
its head throwing it into some lava very
dramatic stuff here and then there's a
another sort of Revelation um the uh the
queen and the king who hasn't been here
the the first man are brought there and
so are the um oares of of the the worlds
of Mars and and Venus um everything has
been brought to the conclusion that it
was supposed to human beings did not
fall the way they did in our world uh
and and Venus is going to be able to go
on on its own but now those humans are
going to enjoy something that we didn't
they're going to be made into sort of
like the uh the rulers of their their
world rather than people alienated from
their world alienated from from the
creatures alienated from the environment
um Ransom gets brought back to Earth and
that's the end of of
paralandra That Hideous Strength I'm
actually going to skip through rather
quickly because I don't want to spend
too much time on it what I'll say is U
it happens in University Town in England
um and it's after the war um the
university has decided to sell some of
its its land to a um you could call it a
a a Consortium of sorts a think tank
called nice and nice stands
for uh the National Institute of
coordinated
experiments so it's kind of a mix of um
state power and scientific technocratic
power and as it turns out um they have
some pretty big plans they want to
subjugate everything to science um they
they um they're actually taking orders
from this severed head that is being
kept alive which is U allowing the uh
you know the the evil um oara and and uh
elil of of this world to communicate
with the humans the humans all have
different ideas about what's exactly
happening some are some are viewing it
in sort of scientific ways some are Vie
it kind of mystical ways um none of them
think of it in in theological terms um
but there's this there's this conflict
going on between nice which has its own
police force um has the power of the
government behind it and eventually
takes over this town and is carrying out
some horrible experiments on people and
the manner which which is
um Ransom and a few other people and uh
is going to eventually include another
old character from aruan Legend
Merlin because the college is actually
uh right on the edge of where Merlin's
tomb is supposed to be and it turns out
Merlin is actually in his tomb in
suspended animation and he comes to life
um and there's there's there's this sort
of you know funny almost Comedy of
Errors Merlin makes a TR TR exchange
clothes with him uh and then um the nice
people come along and they think that
that that is is Merlin and the
is rather inarticulate although he
speaks English they think he doesn't so
they're looking for an interpreter they
actually put out an advertisement in the
paper looking for an interpreter to to
interpret this this guy's a old Celtic
or whatever it is um as it turns out
it's going to be Merlin who actually
goes as the
interpreter but it'll happen after he's
he's himself
possessed possessed by the planetary
oara of the other planets because for a
long time there's been a not not quite a
truce but a um sort of like entrenched
Warfare you know you don't go across the
lines the the orbit of the moon has been
sort of the boundary and the other uh
planetary you know we can call them
rulers or archons or whatever uh they
couldn't go beyond that but by Weston
going to Mars and then Weston going to
to Venus they broke the truce and now
the other planetary powers can come down
what's hinted at here is that this is
sort of the beginning of the end of an
era of
Oppression and it's going to you know
things are going to be uh changing now
and so Merlin goes and he brings the
powers of these other planetary or arsa
to this this company or Think Tank um
there's a massive earthquake the lab
animals get out start start eating the
the bad people um all literally all hell
is breaking loose you know um and so in
a way good triumphs over evil but it's
it's in ways that are almost always
totally
unexpected and uh only Mak sense after
the fact and that's that's typical Lewis
mean there's been this couple involved
in in the whole business mark and um uh
Jan and uh Mark was actually offered a
job in in
nice um almost got turned almost became
part of their apparatus uh when he
doesn't they try to pin a murder on him
that they committed um Jane is his wife
uh he's he's a professor she's a PhD
candidate um their marriage is not very
good um and and and she ends up um you
know getting associated with the manor
at the same time that her husband is
getting connected up with this this
other group by the end they're brought
back together in reconciled as well and
so there this is sort of a symbolic
thing Ransom um gets transported back to
Venus he's he's going to you know be out
of the story and now it's you know sort
of left what's going to happen next
that's that's not really resolved um but
it's a great you know it's a great tale
that's being told um
this is probably a good place to take
any any questions or comments before I
talk about some philosophical themes
associated with this um anything that
comes to mind
or
no well why don't I um talk then about I
I mentioned one of the themes is myth
and
metaphysics so Lewis is working with
um
myth um and he doesn't see myth the way
that many of us moderns do as sort of a
madeup story and said it's a it's it's a
deeper significance to the story and
I've got this this nice passage that
comes from paralandra from these are
ransom's realizations before the man
before he has to fight this this
possessed creature um and these are kind
of uh good starting points for this so
Ransom so it says long since on Mars and
more strongly should be since he came to
paralandra Ransom had been perceiving
that the triple distinction of truth
from
myth uh I try I did this by dictation so
some of these words are not right yeah
and and of both sorry from the fact was
purely terrestrial so we often make a
dis iction between myth and fact Right
facts are just facts you know everybody
can myth is madeup story you know could
be fairy tales could be you know U you
know religious ideas you know the Greek
myths are great example and then
um uh both from from truth was part and
parcel of that unhappy division between
soul and body which resulted from the
fall so that's something in our fallen
state that makes sense to us but it's
not the reality of things so he says
here that on on Venus whatever happened
here would be of such a nature that uh
Earthman would call it
mythological boy all of this I don't
know why why the the dictation has that
in there but all of this um terrible
yeah all of this was talk before yeah
word you know yeah now he knew it um and
he says the presence in the darkness
never before so formidable this is the
presence of God telling him hey you got
to go do this thing for me was putting
these truths into his hand like terrible
Jewels now why does this come up because
Ransom has in the back of his head what
he calls the valuable voice saying God
wouldn't really have you go off and
fight somebody on his behalf that's just
like mythological stuff that people do
in the Bible or you know the Greek gods
did that sort of stuff human beings
don't do that today we're civilized you
know but the voice is that voice is
wrong and the the other you know deeper
voice in the darkness is saying this is
what you have to do and so he comes to
realize that what we take as being just
you know myth or fable or Legend has
really has has the deeper significance
fact is kind of the The Superficial
aspect of things another thing that he
he realizes he says he perceived that
what was to human philologist merely an
accidental resemblance of two sounds was
in truth no accident the whole
distinction between things
accidental um and things designed like
the distinction between fact and myth
was purely
terrestrial the pattern is so large that
within the little frame of Earthly
experience there are pure part pieces of
it between which we can see no
connection and other pieces between
which we can't hence we rightly for our
use distinguish The Accidental from the
essentials but stepping outside of that
frame and the distinction stepping
outside of that frame the distinction
drops down into the void uh fluttering
useless Wings he'd been forced out of
the frame caught up into the larger
pattern and he bowed his head and
groaned and repined against his Fate To
Be Still A man here's a beautiful line
and to be forced up into the
metaphysical world to enact what
philosophy only thinks so the idea there
is that we make distinctions between you
know The Accidental and the the uh
essential or the necessary and the
contingent and those work for us here in
in the frame that we're in but if we
were to grasp the deeper reality of
things as it is we would see that um
there's a much larger pattern that we
belong to and it's not a pattern that um
you know we we're just stuck with and we
can't react against we can if we want to
the next thing uh he says the thing
still seems impossible he's talking
about fighting this creature but
gradually something happened to him
which uh which had happened to him only
twice before in his life in both cases
the thing uh things seemed to be sheer
impossibility he had not thought but
known that being what he was he was
psychologically incapable of doing it
and that you might have had this
experience without any apparent movement
of the will as objective and an
emotional as a reading on a dial that
had risen before him with perfect
certitude the knowledge about this time
tomorrow you will have done the Imp
possible um the future was there fixed
and unaltered as if you'd already
performed it it it was a minor
irrelevant detail that had happened to
occupy the position uh we call Future
instead of that which we call past you
might say if you like that the Power of
Choice had simply been set aside as an
inflexible Destiny substitute for it so
that's the way we sometimes think of it
you know either you have choice or it's
Destiny or fate or
necessity on the other hand he said
you might say he delivered he had
delivered from the rhetoric of his
passions and had emerged into
unassailable Freedom here's a great line
predestination and freedom were
apparently
identical we like to say you know things
like predestination or necessity and
human Freedom are opposites to each
other um in in a strictly theological
sense and you can get this not only in
Lewis but in you know philosophers like
Bo
a great you know Christian philosopher
the uh you know early Middle Ages or
Augustine or an some people that that
Lewis is reading these actually
interfuse with each other the plan is so
complicated that it takes into account
human freedom freedom of of beings that
can like say I'm G to screw up the whole
freaking thing if I can and the plan is
is uh robust enough that it can even
take that into account and turn that
somehow into that part of the the the
pattern so um that is all part of the
metaphysics underlying these worlds
there is a proper order to things now
when we hear this word order we often
think of people telling us what to do
and you know or rules and and it's very
you know kind of top down kind of stuff
that's not the way Lewis sees it at all
instead order is something that allows
us to grow it allows us to be what we
ought to be so for example when when um
you know Ransom is there on the new
world he doesn't go around kicking you
know the the little dragon creature that
he sees because why would you do that
sort of thing whereas the you know the
Diabolical creature goes and just starts
hurting things for for its own sake that
those are both possibilities right but
one fits within the proper order of
things the other doesn't and only by
working within the proper order and
growing within it can one see how things
are to be you can't really force it and
this this takes us towards Lewis's
speculations about technology because if
you think about what technology is in in
many respects it's human beings forcing
things making things go a certain way um
and so sometimes the tool can become the
master uh it's a very dangerous thing
that you know not not Lewis but another
great um a great um French thinker
Gabriel Marcel said um the great risk
for human beings is being at the mercy
of what he called their
Technics uh you know and that we we
we're getting to the point where we he's
writing this 60 years ago you long
before worries about AI or anything like
that have hit the scene he's thinking
we've lost control over technology even
even then um another great theme that
he's got is is rational animals what
does it mean to be a rational creature
um on on Mars there's three different
kinds of rational beings it's not like
here on Earth where we look at ourselves
as being the rational animal par
excellence and every once in a while
maybe wonder about chimps or Elephants
or octopi you know or or even pigs uh
and a few others as well I mean occupy
are pretty pretty amazing I don't know
if you guys saw that recent story about
Inky and his
Escape they're pretty pretty smart it's
a good thing for us probably that they
die so so young and after bating because
boy if they you know they are so smart
that if if they put together a
civilization we might we might be in
trouble given what we sort of nonsense
we pull you know it's an interesting
thing in NPR though that said that they
don't like to socialize with one another
or others so that's probably part of
what's going on there we go yeah they
keep their intelligence to themselves
and you know sort of make do and you
know create but they it said that they
were the guy who works with them it was
clear to point out that it's octopuses
not octopi is the proper plural because
well if it was going to be in the Greek
it should be octopodes well yeah you can
call them but uh yeah they were saying
that um the uh they'll quickly assess
whether or not you're foe or friend and
if you're foe they get away from you and
if they're friend they just kind of like
do their thing you know they they like
well you know it's almost like the cat
of of all sea creatures you know yeah
like what can you do for me really or
Lou Bor has this great line in one of
his essays where he talks about um uh
characteristically British friendships
which Begin by people talking a bit with
each other and end by them sitting next
to each other and and spending hours
together without ever exchanging a word
and being great with
that maybe that's what actify her like
yeah but and to go back to this you know
we're we're now at starting to realize
that like elephants for example are much
more complex in in their behavior than
we we took them to be are they rational
in the way that human beings are um even
our closest you know relatives like The
Chimps um it's it's still pretty pretty
far behind um but there seems to be
something there of that so perhaps it's
it's a gradiation I mean you wouldn't
say a crayfish or a spider is a rational
creature but maybe as we get close Clos
and closer they become that way in
Lewis's
Universe on Mars there's already three
different types of rational creatures
who live together and they do different
things rationality takes different
shapes so the sorns are more
scientifically oriented um they don't do
poetry the uh Rosa they do great poetry
and the sorns are like that's that's
their thing they do that the uh can you
say the name again for me the uh tricky
yeah they they're the ones that are they
work things you know they're almost sort
of like dwarves in a way but they're
they're they're described as being sort
of like a froggish type of creature
um on on Earth there's human beings and
since um madil came as a human being
that's supposed to be like the form that
that rationality is going to take from
this point on so that's why on Venus
that's the ra the shape of rational
creatures what's really interesting is
after all the action on Venus and the
queen and the King are given power over
their own world the queen says in a kind
of off-hand way I think what we'll do is
we'll probably take the the higher
animals and we'll turn them into we'll
we'll train them or or you know teach
them to become that rational animals so
there's this idea that they'll become
elevated maybe we could look at you know
our own relations with some of these
other creatures in our in our own world
that way that maybe maybe elephants
aren't or whales aren't rational
creatures in the way that we are but
perhaps it's because we push them uh
aside um now you could ask well what
would be what would be the the basis for
being able to do that you know wouldn't
technology be important for that and and
it would be right um You can't hear the
the sounds that elephants make that they
can use to communicate over a distance
um but people use
um uh sound technology found out they do
these
subsonic talking back and forth that we
we didn't know about um but there's a
difference between using technology and
then having a you might call a
technocratic or what Lewis is going to
call
scientism view on on things and that
that's that's the third theme that I
wanted to talk about
um Ransom not Ransom Weston rep presents
that and so I gave you some speeches
that that Weston made hopefully these
these don't have such you know goofy
profanity yeah stupid word uh we did I
did that last night as I was trying to
get this done uh so I'd have them ready
but I should have proof checked them
um technology right the tool yeah and
the oppressor shouldn't allowed it to do
it own thing all right so he starts out
with this big speech and this is on Mars
he says our right to supersede you is
the right of a higher over the lower
life is greater than any system of
morality her claims are absolute it is
not by tribal tattoos and copybook
maxims that she's pursued a Relentless
Mark Mark from the amoeba to man and
from from man to to civilization she's
ruthlessly broken down all obstacles and
liquidated all failures and today in her
highest form civilized man um uh with me
as his representative she presses
forward to that interplanetary leap
which will perhaps Place forever beyond
the reach of death um then after later
on when he meets with Ransom he says I
should make it clear the false humanist
ideal of knowledge is an end in itself
never appealed to me I always wanted to
know in order to achieve utility at
first that utility naturally appeared to
me in a personal form I wanted
scholarships and income that generally
recognized position of the world without
which a man has no leverage when those
were attained I began to look further
onto the utility of the human race and
so Weston represents this this SCI what
what Lewis is going to call scientism or
scci you know
uh uh what we would nowadays call
reductionist you know um you know kind
of attitude about things sometimes this
could be called positivist as well in in
uh philosophical terms that thinks that
science has the answer to everything and
science can answer all questions not
only of fact but of value
um now when you do that and you usually
what goes along with that is all the old
answers they're all nonsense get rid of
that unscientific trash you know
civilization what we call civilization
is is the way forward and we will
dominate everything that's that's that's
Weston's View and there's a certain kind
of evil involved in that that doesn't
grasp itself as evil because it thinks
that good and evil aren't are just
subjective views on things you know he
wants to reduce everything to facts a
little bit later he he endorses this
Cosmic spirituality now this is coming
out of sort of a distortion of ber son's
um
Notions says all my life I've been
making a wholly unscientific dichotomy
or antithesis between man and nature I'd
conceived myself as fighting for man
against his non-human environment I
became a convinced believer however in
emergent Evolution all is one the stuff
of mind the unconscious the unconscious
purpose of dynamism
is present from the very beginning man
himself is nothing the forward movement
of Life the growing spirituality is
everything Spirit mind Freedom
spontaneity that's what I'm talking
about that's the goal towards which the
whole Cosmic process is moving the final
disengagement of that freedom that
spirituality is the work to which I
dedicate my home life my whole life and
the life of humanity let's call it a
force a great inscrutable Force pouring
up into us from the very dark bases of a
being a force that can choose its
instrument and Weston sees himself as
being chosen to be the instrument of
that Force doesn't realize it's a
diabolical force and he and he and rans
Ransom says you realize not all Spirits
are good and and won says see you
haven't been listening to me
spirituality is just good by itself uh
I've I've you know moved on from my
previously my opic view don't bother me
with all that religious mumble jumble
that that you've got um this is the
scientific ific View and then he opens
him up himself up for possession at the
very end shortly before he dies uh he
has a much more pessimistic view on
things um of a sort of universe that
that is absurd that that um is a horror
in many ways he says I've been stuffing
myself up with a lot of nonsense all my
life trying to persuade myself that it
matters what happens to the human race
trying to believe anything you do will
make the universe bar
that's why it's so important to live as
long as you can he's got this
interesting metaphor all the good things
are now a little rind of what we call
Life put on for show and then the real
Universe forever and ever to thicken
that rind by one cimeter to live one
week one day one half hour longer that's
the only thing that matters all the dead
have sunk down into the inner Darkness
under the Rind all witless all
twittering gibbering decaying boogeymen
every Savage know that all ghosts hate
the living who are still enjoying the Ry
then he goes on a little bit more he
says you know because R Ransom says
that's really a partial view on things
uh and and you know Weston says you know
you can talk about your God all you
like God is only the god of the living
he's not the god of the Dead um as a
matter of fact God I'm perfectly willing
to say that God exists out outside of
time but we who live in time we go be
you know below the Rind into this
horrible never Neverland that that is
death and that's what it is for most of
our existence uh and your God has
nothing to do with that uh and then um
you know Ransom argues with him a bit
more and um Weston will end up saying
um that uh this is this is all that you
really get so we should just try to live
out as as much uh time as we've got um
it's not going to be particularly good
this is at almost the end of his life
before he he goes goes under and and
dies um now all three of these
perspectives in Lewis's view are bad
perspectives so it's not really a
progress that Weston has made Weston
thinks that he's making a progress from
delusion to truth but he's really just
moving from one delusion to another
delusion to another delusion that's
going to have terrible effects um
and when we get to the third uh book
That Hideous Strength that whole
institution nice sort of represents you
might say like a a whole set of options
of of ways in which you can you can do
this they stand for like the guy who
runs it is actually Divine now erected
into a lord um who
um
uh Lord fever Stone who is is uh
financing the
operation um he's just after power other
people there think that this is going to
be a way of of wiping out everything
that's not truly human in human beings
through technological means which really
means wiping out all the stuff that we
consider human and you know sort of
purifying the world um others are are
tied in to for for for other reasons but
what they want to do is use
technological means to control everybody
and to sort of stamp out what's what's
uh truly human us Lewis says that that
is um objectively evil but it can't
recognize itself as evil one of the
things that that's quite interesting in
the Reflections in this is that um it's
very rare that somebody who is doing
evil can say I am doing evil they're
always doing something else
instead and it takes a lot of courage to
call Badness
Badness to to not you know um just look
away from it and and it pretend it's not
there to um not accept you know easy
explanations for it but to
to um deal with it as it is because it's
very unsettling you know evil is is kind
of a mystery why do people do the
horrible things that they do um this is
something that that really really
bothers us um
the last thing that I wanted to to to
hit on um is a a theme is this this
funny stuff about about
gender um
and there we go I I actually marked some
of the passages rather than printing
them out is probably a good
thing so uh in paralandra after the the
king and queen are um you know sort of
ratified and they did the right thing um
these two
um uh these two Cosmic beings the the
rulers of of Mars and Venus are
described here and Ransom says um Ransom
tried to put it into words he said that
malondra that's that's Mars was like
Rhythm and paralandra was like Melody uh
he goes on and on with this and then he
says um at all events what Ransom saw at
that moment was the real meaning of
gender
everyone must sometimes have wondered
why in nearly all tongues certain
inanimate objects are masculine and
others feminine what is masculine about
a mountain or feminine about certain
trees Ransom has cured me of believing
that this is a purely morphological
phenomenon uh depending on the form of
the word still less is gender an
imaginative extension of sex our
ancestors did not make mountains
masculine because they projected male
characteristics into them the real
process is the reverse gender is a
reality and a more fundamental reality
than sex sex is in fact merely at the
adaptation to organic life of a
fundamental polarity which divides all
created things female sex is simply one
of the things that have feminine gender
there are many others and masculine and
feminine meet us on planes of reality
where male and female would be simply
meaningless masculine is not attenuated
male nor feminine attenuated female on
the contrary the male and female of
organic creatures are rather faint and
blurry reflections of masculine and
feminine so that's an interesting kind
of speculation right there you know the
notion that um we are men and women we
do have sex right uh but that gender in
its strictest sense would be kind of a
cosmic principle that is deeper than
than the sexual division that or or
difference that that we know now it gets
even more complicated
um in That Hideous Strength he talks
about seven
genders um and this is coming from a
medieval speculation remember Lewis was
a medievalist
right so he says
um here we
go the three Gods um you know Venus Mars
and Jupiter another thing these these
angels or you know might call them
planet AR uh Governors they're also what
have appeared to human beings as as Gods
um so the these stories about you know
Mars and Venus and all that they have
some basis for for leis um these three
Gods uh who had already met in the Blue
Room were were less unlike Humanity than
the two who they still awaited Saturn
and
Jupiter in uh Mercury and Venus and Mars
were represented the the two of the
seven genders which bear a certain
analogy to the biological Sexes can
therefore in some measure can be in some
measure understood by man it would not
be so with those who were now preparing
to descend these doubtless also had
their genders but we have no clue to
them these would be mightier energies
ancient ills steeran of giant worlds
which have never from the beginning been
subdued to the Sweet humiliations of
organic life
um so he's saying that the cosmos as as
uh it's not that it doesn't it's not
that it's beyond you know life it's just
kind of a a blank bare void that we
would just be posting you know our own
subjective values onto no instead our
perspective is just sort of you know a
very small bit of a much larger order
that we don't even get but we can see
the intimations of
um it's kind of an interesting idea I'm
not saying I I necessarily endorse it
but it's an interesting idea to play
with and and I think it does play a role
in Lewis's um fiction the as a side note
that seven planets thing and and seven
genders the seven planets of traditional
astrology also show up in the Narnia
series each of those books there's been
a lot of scholarship on this Lewis
clearly Associated each of them with one
of the the planets planets including Sun
and the Moon in traditional astrology so
these are some of the um you know you
might say philosophical underpinnings
and when you got these Keys you can see
more of what's going on in Lewis's books
um I don't want to say that he was doing
philosophy in writing these books he
wasn't he was doing something much
better he was writing
fiction uh and great fiction at that but
if you understand some of these
philosophical themes I think it opens up
um even greater doors to to these novels
so let's let's do questions or
discussion or uh you guys have been very
nice listening to me for all this time
but I'm sure you must have some uh ideas
that you know I I'm I'm good with not
talking for a
while I remember reading them when I was
probably in my early 20s and I was was
thinking now about looking with a very
different sort of critical eye at the
scientists you know the Western speeches
yeah and finding that different things
as you were retelling the story I was
remembering I was like oh yeah and then
that happened and you know I I found
myself uh sort of almost shocked by the
contrast between what I remembered
feeling when I read some of this as a
much younger person than you know
hearing it kind of retold now yeah and
it is it it's you know a lot of the
struggles I think that he presents were
um I think an outcome of of the horror
of of what happened in World War II in
many ways you know and I think that
there were a lot of sort of complex
historical issues that weighed heavily
on his writing that you
know really in a in a different context
looking at it now whether it's you know
the the sort of destruction of the
creature or the grappling with like this
whole idea of being nice and you know
the academy and The Interpreter needed
to understand like basic you know sort
of peasant level English I mean there
are all of these things that I just
think are so
um biting and they still are you know so
my interpretation of certain passages
was very different but I think in a
historical context it's not only really
great Fiction it's a great exploration
into sort of you know human
nature um using these PL planetary
Journeys as a way of going in and
outside of ourselves and and what it is
that we do yeah I think they've aged
well in many respects I mean the the we
now know that space actually is pretty
empty you know because we sent people
out there but but his descriptions of it
are are very nice um but the rest of it
you know wasn't there there was a
butterfly right that was killed in one
of them I remember and it kind of or
something happened somebody was not
supposed to step off a path and they
stepped off a path was that paralandra I
think well Ransom brings to paralandra
sort of the the guilt of human beings
from our world um but he Alters
something right like there's a scene of
altering it's it's West it's Weston
who's who's doing horrible things on
paralandra and like not not just little
ones you know killing animals by the
hundreds when when Ransom won't let him
kill animals he finds plants to ring you
know just
destru for that's what I'm saying like
there's Timeless elements I think a lot
of people connected it because of
historical placement to things that had
happened in the the Nazis yeah but when
you look at you know were written before
World War I ended though well yeah um
right but it was 32 43 and 45 right yeah
so there was a sense of things sort of
coming to light and I think that when I
read it that was sort of the context
that I was provided by the instructor
you know at the time and what I'm saying
is I think now you know know killing
animals by the hundreds I mean you can't
you can't look at anything without
hearing about like you the way the
factory farming has changed and how
we've become ransoms right w w w yeah I
mean if you think about what um farming
meat farming was like 40 years ago
compared to what it's become
today things are so drastically changed
the animals are in such such worse
circumstances they've been reduced to
there's no quality of life yeah there
are on like organic farms and things
like that but but that those are pretty
rare and that's very expensive meat um
and and most people don't don't do
that and um you know as as our world um
over the last 40 years we've also seen a
massive increase in in the middle class
within the third world and along with
that goes uh vastly increased suffering
for for Animals U and Lewis would be one
of the people that say like animals are
not just things there for us to do
whatever we want with they are part of
the natural order that we're supposed to
be respecting well I think the thing
that jumps out at me is the idea that
you know the the people who are doing
the harm are also a victim of that whole
sort of system yeah right to have to
lack the capacity for moral judgment
that would prevent you from doing
something like that makes you part of it
yeah
but how so you've you've read them you
you've read them a long time ago long
time have you read the the space try yes
sir couple times what did you make of it
of the of the series
yeah um I read an essay that leis wrote
it was
in it was in a collection of essays but
I think the name of the essay was
religion and rocketry and he wrote it in
response to a question about the
spiritual or theological implications of
the possibility of life life on other
planets yeah and I kind of saw um I
don't know if that was written before or
after these but it almost seems like
this was him exploring that idea
theologically yeah through a narrative
and and I think I think he did that
beautifully uh I think I think that
within like within the scientific
Community there's
a there isn't much respect for theology
yeah and and probably vice versa as well
but I don't think I don't think Lewis
thought the two were in opposition to
each other yeah when he talks about
scientism he says I don't mean what
actual scientists do I mean what the
people who write about science the
popularizers the HG WS people like that
what they're into you know and I think
it's that still that way today you know
you you talk with you talk with actual
scientists who believe in something like
the scientific method and when you when
a theological question comes to them
they say I can't say anything about that
because that's beyond the realm of my
you know observational capacities I
can't say whether God exists God doesn't
exist that's that's not something
science can answer um but that's not the
way science gets portrayed by a lot of
the people who are more like um Divine
or Weston way that Lewis has has
portrayed them well you know another
thing that's really cool about this so
Ransom is a Christian right and um one
of the things that happens over and over
again ransom's faith gets called into
question in a certain way not in them
like he he you know sees something that
makes them say oh Christianity must all
be nonsense or something but you come
away from this with the idea that um
what we call Christian doctrine would be
in many respects right but much too
limited a
view right what would it be like on on
other planets what would God have
created other rational creatures well if
we only know this world we we don't know
right we just actually go there and find
out and so when somebody's given the
opportunity to go and find out what he
finds out is that the story is even more
more complicated and vast than what he
has been brought up with and so it
doesn't produce like a crisis of Faith
like oh well now I'm finding all the
parts of the story are false but he's
finding out that parts of the story that
he thought were the whole story aren't
the whole story you know uh so like you
know there's speculations in there about
what would it be like on Venus with
these human beings who didn't fall we
only know know our world um and now you
say well well we don't only know our
world because we're able to imagine
that's not the same thing as knowing of
course right but that's that's some of
the genius of a great novelist is being
able to take the imagin attemp and turn
it into something that almost feels like
knowledge for us yeah um I mentioned in
in another
session um Philip K dick in one of his
short stories he's he's got a character
who um is he's having a life crisis or
something like that and he goes to
consult the you know religious Classics
you know so like you might have like a
bunch of volumes on your shelf and so
there's the eing and there's the Bible
and there's I forget what else and then
the last thing that he says is the
tolken because tolkien's uh like
retelling of the story of Middle Earth
got turned into a kind of uh it was
seemed to have enough significance to
have a religious um what would you call
it you know became narrative yeah it
became a classic you know so I mean that
that could make sense like you know a
thousand years from now um maybe maybe
stuff like this could in fact become a
classic that way um I think tolken and
Lewis probably not like that
because they were pretty committed
Christians so I don't think they the
Christian narrative itself eclipsed but
you there's something to it um you know
the other thing
too Lewis is influenced by
um uh
Chesterton have any of you guys have all
read Chesterton before he's he's really
worth reading too a matter of fact
reading chesterton's the Everlasting man
played a major role in Lewis's own
conversion um and Chesterton is an
earlier generation and and but he and
Lewis have a similar attitude towards um
incorporating motifs from Pagan
myths um Chesterton argues in the
Everlasting
man that the Pagan is the real Pagan is
closer to the
Christian than the modern
person without any of that stuff is to
either one of them that
paganism you know went off off the rails
in many respects but it was touching it
at least took things
seriously and the stories that it told
weren't always the right ones but if you
dug deeper you could find the right ones
and then Christianity shows up to
provide a more comprehensive framework
in which um these things would fit and
then Lewis is saying basically with this
well there's an even more comprehensive
framework than than that um whereas the
modern person just rejects all of it as
as you know to use a word that they
liked BOS you know or bunk um English
have some great words uh and what this
goes back to in the Middle
Ages you would find these things that
the religious reformers often saw as
being sort of just um lapses into
paganism but work really uh for example
um uh camos this this uh Portuguese
author um he wanted to produce something
like the Odyssey or the anad um for for
the Portuguese and so he wrote it it's
called
idades um and in it vashko deamus um
travels uh all the way to India and it's
within a Christian worldview so God is
there and yet the Greek gods are all
there too and so You' be like what
what's going on here how can this be
compatible either you have Christianity
or you have the Greek gods can't have
both um well for somebody like camoes
you can and for somebody like
Lewis uh studying people like that or
Chesterton you can because you can have
this very rich overarching system in
which they all kind of fit together um
you don't see a lot of philosophers
talking in that way you see literary
people talking that way in the 20s
Cy
um you know um just for what it's worth
yeah a reminder that May 12th is the
next one on asof but tonight we doing
yeah but tonight at nine: talk about a
hard Science Guy yeah well if you have
scii they are showing Lewis's line witch
in the Wardrobe movie oh yeah yeah cool
I got a little alert good because I have
you know searched
for so BP with the like the TV guides
but I'm sitting here thinking about the
the
overarching civilization created by
Herbert oh in the Doom Series yeah and
the religion the Rel very different take
on religion from very different take
yeah on religion of politics yeah but he
takes it on yeah we're GNA talk about
him coming up too in great detail
spots you know you could say that if
Lewis is um able to reave into his
narrative
the better potentials of
religion uh Herbert is much more attuned
to the dark potentials on religion for
social control for um leading people
into uh factions and things like that um
yeah the benas is supposed to be the
Jesuit you
know his book Charter House Dune when I
read Charter House Dune I was in
graduate
school and and there the ties to
political minations oh yeah were just
spot on
yeah just spot on at the time yeah I
this is getting that's June by the way
it hert is June 9th yeah yeah and then
zelas is July 14th yeah with zelas we're
going to talk about um Amber and chaos
and this this uh I'm actually going to
talk about
neoplatonism because his metaphysics
there is a neoplatonic one um yeah
Herbert is is uh mean it's interesting
if you think
about religion the way a lot of people
seen it is something that's supposed to
die out right with with with human
beings becoming truly civilized and
enlightened and and all that and that
has now become such an old story that
it's taken out it's it's it's you know
when somebody says something like that
it's not it's not something new um
in the enlightenment they they they
really did think they were saying
something new and I suppose even in the
19th century with positivism and you
know religion is going to go away and um
religion has remained a vital force for
good or for
bad um in human
societies uh and it still is today and
presumably when we go out to space or
who knows what's going to happen it's
going to go there too you know um so I
suppose that it becomes incumbent upon
us to make sure that we've kind of got
things at least halfway figured out
before we go out to space William James
addressed it in the late 1800s yeah when
he did his Edinburgh
lectures um and you about the varieties
of varieties of religious experience
yeah William James those were the um
gford lectures right they were the G
lectures in in Edinburgh yeah and his
conclusion after all the lectures was
yeah it's not going away no that
humankind needs something bigger psych
he was a psychologist yeah and
philosopher he was was he philosopher
yeah he he's the he's the guy who stole
pragmatism CS Pur comes up with the word
pragmatism and James popularizes it and
it turns out to be something very
different than what purse had in mind so
purse changes the name to pragmaticism
and says that such an ugly word that
nobody will bother stealing it so James
gets to take over the word but yeah he
those those lectures are wonderful um
you know and and uh James is not himself
you know you know a practitioner of
religion but but he thought there was
something there that we we can't just
ignore not if we're good scientists you
know um well he did those lectures at a
time when atheism was on the rise yeah
Church of Christ scientist was created y
um there was the Emer emergence of a
whole bunch of different approaches to
religion yeah at that at that moment in
history and he was looking at it through
that lens what I particularly like about
those lectures um and part of what I
like about James in that respect is he
he is somebody who can read other
people's
literature what he did in order to
prepare for that and he doesn't have to
believe what they're believing is true
but he can be sort of a sympathetic
Observer there's a kind of fundamental
respectfulness there in on his part that
I really like you see that with some
people in comparative religion where you
know they're never going to become a
Muslim or a Buddhist or or a Hindu um
like htin Smith for example but they can
um think about what it might be like to
occupy that that frame of mind and see
even though they'll say Yeah in the end
I'm not buying it they they can they can
see how somebody could be rational and
um a good person and say this this makes
good sense for me um and yet still be
able to pull back from it you know and
not say well it's all just pick whatever
you want or something like that there's
something very admirable about that I
think you know that often is missing in
in um you know theist atheist penics
there's a lot of um apologetics in the
bad sense happening on both sides where
they're just trying to shout each other
down or argue each other
something
um you know again to go back to
Chesterton Chesterton was a big fan he
wrote several stories like this where
you have a atheist character and then
you have a Christian character and um
they fight with each other but they're
both fundamentally decent
guys and then they wind up being opposed
to the the rest of the world where
there's some atheist
institution staffed with a bunch of
jerks and then you know the church in
some respect staffed by another bunch of
jerks and um they wind up having to make
common cause he does that in the ball
cross he does that in flying in he does
that in a lot of the uh
um oh that the Father Brown story are
are kind of like that um and other
people have picked up on that too Graham
green wrote a really interesting book
called monior kiote where he plays off
on exactly the same thing there it's in
Spain and there's a a guy who's a um a
socialist mayor I think and then there's
a priest manior kote and they take off
in kot's car Rosen
an they have
Adventures
uh and they both get in trouble um with
with the state and with the
church and they they formed this very
strong friendship there's also um
another thing of that Motif the little
world of Don Cameo um I don't remember
the guy who wrote it but it's the same
thing you've got a a parish priest and a
communist mayor of a town in Italy and
they can't stand each other and they're
fighting with each other all the time
until they realize that their real enemy
is is not each other but um the the
institutions that that oppress them and
oppress their their peasants and you
know there there's kind of a standing up
for a common Humanity that Chesterton
was all about William James is about I
think Lewis is about as well you
know you that's taking us really far a
field though interesting yeah well
should we wrap up I I know that they
want to get us out of here before it's
too late so thanks very much for for
coming and um we'll pick up with uh Azon
is next time all right
yep